>>Kate: The objective
of this lesson was
to use a project-based
learning activity
to have the students teach
one another the key concepts
for chemistry.
Students are really engaged
when technology is involved.
>>So get a partner, quietly
sit, and set a goal together.
>>Kate: The assignment is
for students to work in pairs
and to develop a lesson to
present to the students.
I'm really big on trying to hit
all the different types of learning,
so they were required to have three
main categories, and under that,
they got to choose how they did it.
So the first category was
to have some type of visual
for our visual learners,
so that could be a
PowerPoint, a video, a poster.
>>Boy: Right now we're using Google Docs,
so we're using Google Presentations,
and we're going to make
the presentation slides
and stuff like that.
>>Kate: The second category was to be
some type of handout for our students
that like to take notes
and write along.
>>Boy: We'll just give them
notes, and the notes,
they're like fill-in-the-blank, so
they have to look at our presentation
in order to finish the notes.
>>Kate: And then the final
category was to do some type
of engaging activity, such as a
crossword puzzle or a word search.
>>Boy: Yeah, I think projects
make learning more effective.
I feel if you're hands-on with
everything, you'll learn it better.
>>Kate: It is a biology
class. However, next year,
due to budget cuts, we
won't be having chemistry
as one of our core sequence.
However, I felt it was
definitely necessary
that they got some more
prerequisite skills for chemistry,
so I decided to switch my
end-of-the-year project
to more of a chemistry idea.
>>Kate: Use your resources.
>>Kate: The first thing that most of
them have done are like the Keynote,
and then I find that they tend to
go with a handout because that comes
with the Keynote, and then
their final stage is going
to be the activity.
Some of them are doing chemical
reactions, and so they want
to create a volcano and do the
vinegar and the baking soda.
Recently our school has
been engaging in Google Docs
and Google Presentations because all
of our students have an e-mail
address based upon our school that's
through a Google account.
And on the Google Docs, they can
have Word and Presentations and stuff
like that because it enables
students to share with one another
if they're working with partners,
and it also enables teachers
to see what they are
doing and easily edit.
>>Boy: And we sign into our school
email and we go into Documents
and it opens up all the projects
we've done, all the essays,
and then we go into Presentation,
and we can make one of these
like little presentation things.
>>Kate: But it's really neat because
one student can be at home working
on it while the other student can
be at school and working on it.
It also decreases the hassle of
having students have to bring
in flash drives or saving it and
not remember where they saved it.
>>Boy: So right now I'm
moving the picture,
and you can see it
on his computer too.
So right now, see, he's on the
same slide as I am or basically
on the same presentation, so he
can see everything that I'm doing
in the presentation to benefit
it or change something up.
>>Kate: This was specifically a
project, as well, because I know
as a teacher I learn the material
best when I have to present
and teach it to another person,
so I feel like they are best able
to learn the knowledge when they
feel like they have to teach it.
It's higher stakes.
>>Girl: If you're trying to find out
how much 4.5 kilograms is in grams,
you would set up a
proportion like this.
>>Kate: Today, Natalie and Nikki
presented on the different SI units,
so kilograms and stuff like that.
They gave the students guided notes,
so the guided notes
have the key points
and then have fill-in-the-blanks
so that students can follow
along and listen as well.
>>Girl: Since 1960, scientists
use a set of units called SI.
>>Kate: They also had some practice
problems, so they did one as a class
and then they have practice
problems for the students to work on.
A lot of these students
are very tech-savvy,
and they already know
how to do this stuff.
>>Kate: We provide them with
different ideas and resources,
like the Google Docs, but
if they have other ways
to get their point across, like
Pinterest or some other type
of technology that they know
about, they are more than welcome
to use that, as long as
it gets the point across.